шановний мужній героїчний український
народ Дорогі колеги перше засідання
цьогорічне Верховною Радою України Я
думаю об'єднує всіх нас однією думкою
думкою про тих героїв які сьогодні
поблизу солідара поблизу бахмута всіх
інших точках фронту тримають небо
українська тримають фронт і ми
усвідомлюємо якою важкою ціною дається
сьогодні захист кожного метру
української території І власне говорячи
стратегічно в перший день засідання
цього року маємо намалювати ті високі
цілі як ми на нашому парламентському
фронті маємо допомогти Українській армії
здобути перемогу звичайно в першу чергу
нас має об'єднати робота над
євроінтеграцією і
євроатлантичною інтеграцією для того щоб
якнайшвидше пройти цей шлях але
дипломатії між парламентській діяльності
Маємо зробити все для того щоб
наздогнати країну-агресора для того щоб
посилити санкції проти російської
федерації і було створено трибунал для
кримінальної відповідальності
злочинно-вбивчого путінського режиму і
всіх росіян причетних до російської
агресії і коли ми говоримо про те що
сьогодні українці вимагають
відповідальності то маємо думати і про
те наскільки сьогодні є чутливим питання
відповідальності і солідарності власне
для нашої політичної команди коли ми
згадуємо бої які сьогодні точаться
поблизу солідару і бахмуту це має і дуже
особисто смерзне значення там зараз
воюють члени нашої партії зокрема
Олександр погребицький депутат Київської
міської поради і досі проти Олександра
погребиського відкрита кримінальна
справа за начебто напад на представника
забороненої партії о пзж пана Волошина
запитаємо А де Волошин цих 11 місяців
ніхто жодного дня не бачив його в
сесійній залі в той час коли людина яку
звинувачують по цьому нападу в соледарі
захищає наше право тут знаходитись так
само десь в бігах знаходяться десятки
членів цієї забороненої партії А інше я
хочу сказати причетні були до написання
псевдо маніпуляційних політичних справ
проти Генерала марченка і досі не
закрита справа проти Генерала
павловського і досі не закрита справа
десятки політичних справ проти тих людей
які сьогодні кров'ю захищають країну
українці сьогодні вони вимага це
справедливості і наш з вами Солідар має
бути Всесвіт